uh so let's start with one of the
deepest questions humans have ever asked
themselves
we're not messing around in this class
we're going for it and one of the
deepest questions is where does
knowledge come from
and as you'll know if you've taken even
a teeny bit of philosophy or read even a
teeny bit you know that some of the kind
of classic views in western philosophy
especially the empiricist lock and hume
argue that all knowledge comes from
experience
right
on the other hand there are all a number
of other schools of thought on western
philosophy of which a dominant figure is
emanuel kant who argued that experience
alone is not enough
you can't just have experience and
figure out all the stuff we have figured
out
and so he argued that there has to be
what he called a priori
conditions of cognition which can't be
derived from experience themselves but
have to be given prior to it
okay so you have to you have to have to
build some structure into a mind or
brain to get it off the ground it can't
just start with absolutely nothing and
get anywhere
okay and he also argued that one of the
key elements of this a priori structure
that you have to build in
was space and time
okay
organizing principles of
cognition and thinking
and so in his version of it space is
nothing but the form of all appearances
of outer sense and it can be given prior
to all actual perceptions and so exist
in the mind a priori
and can contain prior to all experience
principles which determine the relations
of these objects
okay
well
is that just empty philosophical hot air
um it's kind of hard to understand
exactly what he means you actually have
to go spend
a good deal of time with kant reading
him to make any sense of it
or cheat and get your friends to tell
you as i do
but no i'll argue it's not just empty
philosophical hot air
that these are in some important sense
empirical questions and there are
empirical questions that our field
addresses very directly
okay
and so on wednesday we'll talk about
whether
your representations of space in your
head are innate or not it's pretty much
directly what kant
is talking about or the modern version
of what he was talking about
and today we'll talk about which aspects
of the brain are renate and which are
learned okay that's the agenda
okay
so this little kind of easter egg brain
here
very schematically shows you some of the
regions that we've been talking about in
this class so far with regions that are
to varying degrees specialized for
processing things like shape and color
and motion and faces and places and
bodies right visually processing all of
these things in approximately those
locations
and as i've mentioned these regions uh
are present in approximately the same
location with some individual
variability in pretty much every normal
person
one of my lab members says you keep
saying that it's just not true there's
like some percent of subjects who just
don't show these things he's kind of
right okay so maybe like i don't know
five ten percent of subjects you
wouldn't see some of these things and
we've never actually done the serious
work of bringing those subjects back
scanning the hell out of them and
finding out whether they were just
asleep in the scanner it was a bad
scanner day or whatever it was
i bet they all have them and it's just
sometimes you don't see it but i'm
trying to be a little more honest okay
but you just look at this even this very
schematic version of it you say like how
would you build this system how would
you start with an embryo and build into
a genome or build into whatever
experience is going to happen
to this developing organism how would it
end up with this very particular
structure with those things in
approximately the same place or at least
the same relative positions in all
subjects like the face bits are always
lateral to the color bits the place bits
are medial to the color bits
the kind of shape bits are out on the
lateral surface it's like always like
that how do you build a system like that
i find it hard not to immediately think
well some aspect of this must be innate
or how would it be so damn similar in
each individual
right
um
but it's not the only hypothesis
um
some big part of it even if some aspect
of this is innate
some big part of it may also be learned
or derived from experience
okay so what do you guys think
do you think the fact that these
structures are in systematically the
same place across subjects mean you have
to
build in all that stuff somehow figure
out how to get a a bunch of a's and t's
and g's and c's in your dna to give you
a blueprint for how to build that
structure
what do you think
yeah
it's i mean it's a combination but it's
hard to then think about
how that system evolves over time
generations
yeah so to some extent
experience what i mean here is learn
from experience within each individual
like you could argue that innate really
means
learn through the experience of our
ancestors and hence wired into the dna
yeah
anyway i find this not an obvious
question and so we'll talk about what
what the data say here
so first of all we're going to do some
very basic facts about brain development
just to get the picture of what we're
talking about physically with the
development of brains
so we can ask what is present at birth
and so turns out that most of the
neurons in the adult brain
uh are generated before birth okay so
most of the actual neurons are generated
early you're not making whole a whole
lot more after birth a few but not a lot
further the current view is that most of
the long-range connections that means
like a connection between this part and
that part of the brain are also present
at birth
okay
nonetheless even though a lot of stuff
is present at birth a lot of stuff
changes in the first couple years of
life
most obviously the brain doubles in
volume in the first year
from a two-week-old to a one-year-old to
a two-year-old
right
um
the cortical thickness
you can see here the dark stuff which is
the gray matter out there
increases
sharply between years
one and two
but also the complexity of each
individual neuron increases dramatically
in the first few years of life so here's
a schematic picture of a piece of gray
matter here where you have some number
of neurons here with a few little
you know processes and a few connections
and over
the first couple years of life those
connections get much more dense
and the neurons get much more complex
okay
okay and the final thing that really
matters early on in development is that
myelination
happens rapidly in the first few years
and remember
myelin this is a little reminder neuron
with that yellow stuff which is a bunch
of cells that wrap around the axons the
long processes of a neuron and that
myelin sheath builds up a lot over the
first couple of years and that's
important because the myelin sheath
enables those neurons to send their
signals faster down their axons okay
okay and this is just a picture of
different of a vertical slice like this
through the anatomy of
infants of different ages from 107 days
up to about a year and the colored stuff
in the middle is degree of myelination
which you can see with various kinds of
anatomical scans you can see it starts
at 107 days with a tiny little bit in
the middle and it gets more and more
myelinated and moves from center to
periphery
over the first year of life
okay so all those
uh fiber pathways are getting kind of
accelerated as they get wrapped with
myelin and head and head sped up
okay
um
all right so bottom line
is most neurons and long long-range
connections are in place at birth but
development continues rapidly in the
first two years
especially increasing complexity of
neurons and synapses and myelination of
long-range connections and white matter
okay so it's just basic anatomy nothing
functional yet
okay now we're going to consider in some
detail the case of face perception
not really because that's what i work on
or used to work on mostly
but just because there's a very rich set
of data where people have grappled with
this question in the case of face
perception next time we'll talk about
the navigation network and reorientation
what parts of that system might be
and ate and learned so
so i'll just say right out at the
beginning that this is an extremely
active area where every time i turn
around another paper comes out that
contradicts a previously published
finding and so
that makes it fun but it means there
isn't going to be some really tight
perfect story here and i'd rather take
you guys straight to the cutting edge
even though it's kind of a mess
then give you a nicely packaged but
surely wrong picture okay because again
i think what matters most in this area
is how do you go about answering these
questions rather than what is the
current state of the thoughts about the
answers okay so how are we going to
think about how does face perception
develop
well just to get started i'm going to
show you a very brief movie
of a 72 hour old monkey
see what you think
he's sleepy
he's pretty interested in that face
and watch now
pretty cute huh
so what do you think
um
what does this tell us about face
perception
yeah the charge is moving
good question good for you
clearly is that right quiet quietly all
right
um
uh yes so clearly asked did they try
moving just anything in front of him
absolutely the right question so that
monkey seems pretty interested in that
face but a face is a moving thing motion
is very salient to young primates humans
and monkeys and many others absolutely
um what else did you see in here
yeah it started
yeah kind of i mean the the person
the adult human there was moving their
mouth open like this
and then he was doing something with
their mouth so
what would that require
yeah good question good question 72
hours is damned early but it's not zero
experience right so who knows what
they've managed to pick up that early
they're actually studies in humans which
i'm hoping heather knows better than me
those andy meltzoff things how young are
those humans those are like first hour
yeah so there's studies in humans where
you can show versions of that with um
newborn infants copying you know the
experimenter comes up and sticks their
tongue out at the infant and the infant
does that back kinda sorta certainly
within the first two days maybe even
earlier
okay
okay so it's very suggestive it's
tantalizing but we need control
conditions it doesn't tell us right
everything we need to know
okay so if we think about it
there's sort of ends of the kind of
hypothesis space about how all of this
could go
as alana mentioned everything is both
kind of genes and experience that's true
but they're very very importantly
different ways in which genes and
experience can act together some in
which a big part of the you know heft of
the uh of what um what the adult form
has might be built in and other stories
where most of the structure comes from
experience so just because everything is
both doesn't mean we shouldn't flesh out
exactly what comes from what
so on the kind of one end of the
spectrum
you might imagine that there's some very
very rudimentary precursor
that has to be built in
plus a learning mechanism
okay or a bunch of rudimentary
precursors which are just there to get
the system to learn in the right way
okay
and so we'll talk um shortly about the
idea that there might be some kind of
innate template for faces that gets
monkeys and humans to look at faces and
then the idea is once you get them to
look at a face then experience can take
over from there and do the rest okay so
you got to get them to collect the right
input
uh and there's lots of interesting
computational work going on now where
people are using various computational
models to say
what can develop what do we have to
build into say a convolutional neural
network or some other kind of
computational model
to get it to do some complicated thing i
just came from a job talk the last hour
really amazing talk where guys showing
that if you build in basically
curiosity early on in a network you get
much more general learners than if you
build in um a
a bunch of goals for a developing
network to to seek anyways very active
area
and the paper that i just decided to
assign to you guys just kind of skim it
and get the gist right the basic idea
this is from shimon almond is a very
deep thinker in this field and he argues
that
hands are very important and infants
faces are important but so are hands
because hands do stuff and we're social
primates and we want to learn from other
social primates like our parents and
watching their hands is extremely
informative whatever they're doing with
their hands is probably stuff we need to
learn about
and further we need to know where
they're looking right so gay's
perception like i think i did this demo
before if i'm talking to you guys when i
start doing that it's really hard even
though you know i'm just faking you out
not to like have your attention pulled
over there right
and infants need to learn that as well
so shimon olmen's basic idea is you can
start with an extremely rudimentary
system
and all you have to build in is this
idea that he calls mover right so the
idea is that if you look in a whole set
of say youtube videos and you just look
for patches of the image that are moving
that's no good it won't be a hand it
might be a you know a whole animal or a
face or something else but if you look
in youtube videos or proxy for natural
experience it's okay it's not perfect
but it's something you look for a patch
of the image that moves over
and then causes another previously
stationary image patch to move
that's what happens when we pick stuff
up okay and so his idea is you can build
in this extremely simple thing mover
right which is a very simple visual
algorithm can find image patches that
move over and cause another image or
then then the two image patches move
together and mover will enable you to
identify hands in images pretty well he
looks in youtube videos and shows that
it's really good at picking out hands
and then further once you've picked out
hands that's a really important teaching
signal and teaching you to read gays
because often people look at their hands
before they do things with them
yeah so the idea is there's a very
active ferment now in computational
modeling saying how can we start with
just the most rudimentary minimalist
stuff that has to be built in
and then build on experience to get the
rest from there is that idea sort of
clear it's worth reading that paper
though it's beautifully written he's
brilliant okay so that's the kind of one
end of the spectrum nobody thinks that
you um that you learn absolutely
everything from experience you got to
build in something plus we know all
those neurons are there at birth and so
the idea is like some version
the minimalist
minimalist nativist view says you build
in a few very rudimentary things and
they're enough to bootstrap learning
okay
on the other end of the spectrum
uh you might think and many have
proposed that we're born with a you know
nearly adult-like system that only needs
kind of fine-tuning from experience
right nobody nobody thinks that
zero experience is necessary that would
be kind of crazy
um or implausible
um but on the other extreme uh this view
is that most of the stuff is built in
okay everybody get the theoretical space
here that we're considering
okay so what kind of data can constrain
these questions
uh well one obvious question is what is
present at birth right what is the
initial state or as close as we can get
to it okay
then we can ask how does the system
change over time from birth onward
and then we can ask what are the causal
roles of experience and biological
maturation in that change after birth
okay so that's kind of the whole set of
questions we need to answer to
understand how development works
and a very central if not the central
challenge of development
is that um experience and maturation are
deeply confounded as you look from birth
onward
right so five-year-olds are both more
mature they've had more time for their
biological systems to wire themselves up
including their bodies and their brains
and the whole bit and maybe some of that
is just kind of a on a maturational kind
of autopilot but they've also had a lot
more experience so one of the central
challenges of development is try to
figure out how those later stages like
two months old one year old 10 years old
how that how how those changes that
happen between birth and those stages
can how can we tease apart which of that
came from just you know maturation and
which came from experience all right
okay
importantly things that happen well
after birth
um need not be learned
right
right so think about puberty puberty is
going to happen around 10 11 12 right
and okay you gotta eat and have some
basic inputs to your system but it's
pretty much going to happen right it's
not a product of what you were taught
right or the particular information that
landed on your sensory
receptors i'm sure there's some obscure
influences that i don't know about but
mostly it's on a developmental autopilot
it's just going to happen okay so keep
in mind this is really important the
things that happen well after birth
aren't necessarily learned it might be
just maturation that's continuing right
okay just as like being five feet tall
versus a foot and a half tall isn't
really learned it's just a maturational
you know
program that unfolds
okay so we can ask these three questions
um both behaviorally and neurally and
ultimately we want them to tell the same
story when i said there's some chaos in
this field right now i mean that
basically they're not converging very
well yet but that's fun
sort of
sometimes it's aggravating but mostly
it's fun okay so let's start with some
behavioral data so let's consider the
initial state of face perception in
newborns okay
so we can ask what kind of perceptual
phase perceptual abilities are present
in newborns and we can ask whether they
can detect a face that is destr
discriminate a face from a non-face
whether it's a body or an
object or something else
we can ask about preferred attention to
faces do they to newborns want to look
at faces more than non-faces
we can ask about the ability to
recognize faces to discriminate one face
from another
okay
um and we can ask about the ability to
recognize faces across image changes
right so we spent a lot of time in the
first few lectures talking about the
central problem of invariance in
envision about how do you know that this
image that you're looking at here is the
same person as that image even those are
those are very different images
and actually this image on your retina
right now
uh is more different than this image on
your retina than if we got one of you
and came up had you come up here and
had you look forward so the image
changes that result from a change in
orientation are greater than the image
changes that result from a change in
identity so it's a big computational
challenge when is that solved
and then there are these kind of
so-called signatures of face perception
uh that we've talked about a little bit
for example the inversion effect recall
the inversion effect is larger in
magnitude for faces than non-faces so we
can ask when
uh those things develop okay so let's
start with face detection and face
preferred attention to faces
well so classic studies from the early
90s and actually some of them going back
to the 70s uh did the following very
low-tech thing a low-tech drawing of a
low-tech experiment you take a newborn
infant in this case they're you know
less than an hour old right you've got
to set up in maternity wards
you want the data that's what you do
um of course you have to ask the parents
and all of that
but then you take this infant and you
sit them on a person's lap with video
camera overhead
and you move different objects over the
infant's head
okay and the different objects that were
moved in this case were
were patterns that were drawn on this
paddle that's moved over the infant's
head
and the pattern could be a schematic
face like that
a scrambled schematic face like that and
a blank with nothing in it okay
and what you measure is how far does the
infant turn their head or their eyes
following that paddle as you move it
over them
okay nice low-tech measure
and what you find is they turn their
heads and their eyes farther when it's
an actual schematic face than when it's
a scrambled schematic face or a blank
okay within an hour of birth
now you can still say well their their
parents probably smiled at them quickly
before they were snatched away to do the
experiment
so they had some face experience but boy
not a whole lot and this is a very
abstract face here so this has long been
taken as one of the key bits of evidence
that
something
seems likely to be innate about faces
okay
but now what needs to be innate for that
right
um
and it's a kind of bizarre thing where
this happens in the first two months of
life and goes away and there's a lot of
consideration of what that means maybe
the first two months is enough to
bootstrap learning in the way i was just
talking about bootstrapping getting
attention to the right places
um
but there's also a huge literature of
this phenomenon where there's a big
debate about exactly how simple those
cues need to be so people have done many
variations of this
and one
dominant story
is that all you need is a pattern that
has more stuff on the top than on the
bottom
okay
and that's enough that infants will
follow this more than that
uh and the idea is that in the visual
environment of an infant that's
sufficient to pick out faces
okay so there's been pushback against
this view as well it's probably a little
more complicated than that we won't go
down the rabbit hole of all those
details but whatever it is it's pretty
simple
okay so this is another example of what
i was mentioning before with the omen
case this is a this is a case where it
may be possible to build in something
pretty basic
a pretty basic template and then let
learning take it from there
make sense if the infants are looking at
faces then they can use some kind of
synaptic plasticity whatever and learn
from their experience to discriminate
one face from another okay
so these things are present uh within a
day or two
what about discrimination of individual
identity
first problem how are we going to be
able to tell what a newborn can see
all right
and so i didn't want you guys to be too
thrown by this method in the last
assignment so i told you where there's a
version of the
explanation i'm just going to give so if
you already watched that my apologies
you can read your email for a minute um
so
the classic experiment
a classic experiment
that enabled us to really kind of ask
how a newborn nonverbal infant and what
they see in the world uh was done by
kelman and spelke liz spelhy up at
harvard was at the forefront of getting
this method to really tell us a huge
great deal about what infants see and
understand about the world and this
method that i'm about to show to you has
been the basis of what's sometimes
called the infancy revolution which is
basically the insight that actually
infants know a lot their perceptual
systems are really sophisticated they
know about physics they know all kinds
of social stuff within a few months of
life they know a lot and that's been a
radical change in our understanding of
development based on just behavioral
work so here's the method
okay so what spelkey did i always forget
to bring the demo hang on one moment
we don't need much okay
okay so she showed infants
stuff like this okay my hand the two
hands are not there you just arrange to
see this okay
so even if you hadn't seen me imagine if
you hadn't seen me pick up the phone in
the pen and you didn't already know what
they were
and you're seeing this okay that's what
they see
okay
and so now the question is when infants
see that do they think that that's this
this thing
behind a rectangle or do they think it's
two separate bits moving behind the
rectangle it could be two separate bits
moving together right everybody get the
question
okay so how would we know what the
infants thought was back there
okay
well we use what's known as habituation
of looking time again you sit the infant
on a parent's lap and you show them
stuff and you just measure how long they
look it's magnificently low-tech
but really profound okay
so what we're going to show here is how
long the infant looks on each trial
as a function of
how many times you do it
so you show the infant this the first
time and they look for 40 seconds that's
a long time you show them again they
look for 35 seconds and so forth and by
the fifth or sixth time the infant is
bored
like been there done that bored
right
okay now they're bored now we have a
moment to say okay what did you think it
was
and so now what you can ask is
what are they um what do they think
you then show them either this or this
and you ask them which of those they're
bored to
right so the idea is
if when looking at this they thought
there was a continuous line behind the
occluder
then they should be more bored by this
but if they thought that was two
separate pieces then they should be more
bored by that does that make sense
because it's the same thing they're
already bored with it's not exactly the
same the occluder isn't there but
right but it's more similar
okay so here's the data here's what they
find so what does that mean what do the
infants see when you show them this
it's right there in the data look at the
the first test trial here this is the
first test trial when you show the
the complete line or the broken line
what do they see here
yeah they saw the complete one that's
why when you present the complete one
again they're still bored
already saw that make sense
so isn't that awesome it's so low-tech
and so simple but this is how you can
ask an infant what do you see
yeah
why does it switch positions
you know frankly i never understand why
infant development people do a second
and third trial seems to me by this
point the jig is up i think it's just
because it's hard to get enough infants
and you need more data and so they do a
second third trial but to me that's a
diagnostic one and that's probably not a
significant switch but whatever's going
on out there is obviously much less
important than this heather do you have
a better answer than that why do they do
those other trials they always do and it
just seems like what
yeah i don't either
oh you do it every which way but you do
it pretty fast you know they get bored
and you don't want to wait half an hour
and come back right and you can do that
then that would be a memory question
right
um
yeah
jimmy i'm just curious uh is this
conserved between inputs do they all see
complete lines or
it's pretty robust well okay so first of
all these methods are awesome that you
can learn these kind of deep things
about perception in infants um but these
data are noisy as hell there's no error
bars on this plot but i bet if there
were you'd have to run a lot of infants
to
get to the point where you reach
significance because a lot of times the
infants will just you know throw up or
you know they'll just do what they do
all kinds of random things so the data
extremely noisy and it's very hard to
get enough data within an infant to say
anything about the difference between
one infant and another by the way
there's an there's a very exciting
development going on in this department
right now where kim scott who's a former
grad student of this department has
figured out how to do looking time
experiments like this online
okay and that's hugely important because
the number one bottleneck in this kind
of developmental research has been
finding enough infants
or getting enough data per infant and so
i think that's she's going to just crack
it wide open talia
i guess i'm a little bit confused how we
know like what the infant like really
saw based on how long they've looked at
something
like
could it be that maybe they look at like
the
like maybe they look at the broken
sticks longer because it's like what
they thought was behind it so they're
like now excited that they get to see it
maybe but then why would you get this
so we know from this that the more
familiar it looks the less time they
look
so you would have to come up with yeah
there's there's wiggle room in these
data but you'd have to come your account
would have to say why would they look
less and less and less long when we
repeat the exact same thing
right and you could you could tell a
story like okay
you know it's it's a little bit
different because the occluder isn't
there but it's a little bit the same and
that's kind of edgy and fun or you know
you could tell another story but i think
the bulk of the developmental literature
shows that when you do this kind of
stuff it's a change that makes infants
look more
i'm going to go on unless they're
questions of clarification just because
there's so much other cool stuff okay
so
um
uh okay so how can we use this to study
face recognition that was just a sidebar
on the method
okay so there's a lab in italy where
they have a infant psychology lab next
to a maternity ward and they've been
doing all these awesome studies
um okay and they test one to three day
old infants
and so one of the things they did is
show infants just like the paradigm i
just showed you they show you they show
the infant the same face again and again
and again that's the habituation phase
and then you sh um this is a slightly
different one you give them a choice of
whether they
uh actually you don't give them a choice
i take it back yeah you showed this
condition or that condition
and you see how long they look at each
uh across different infants and so this
is the same person from a different
viewpoint actually pretty subtle as we
discussed with the jenkins study way
back
and that's a different person that
viewpoint and what they found
is that there's a it's hard to see but a
very low p level means that there's a
significant difference in how much the
infants looked at those two
so that's pretty amazing one to three
day old infants can apparently
recognize the identity of a face
a novel individual they don't already
know
with similar looking faces without hair
and a cross view changes wow
right so that's pretty impressive
um okay and so then they've done all
kinds of other variants if you have them
rotate all the way from front profile
there's no longer a significant
difference infants can't do that
and then they do all kinds of other
variants if you show them the same
individual and then habituate to that
they can tell the difference between
viewpoint that's the same and that's
different
right even though it's the same identity
so you can use this to test what they
think is same or different which is a
deep question to ask if you're
interested in representations and
cognition the question of
what an infant or an animal or a bunch
of neurons thinks is the same or
different is the essence of
characterizing what it represents yeah
quite quietly
uh down here
yeah yeah they do so here basically it's
either identical or it's different in
some respect
so
like given a choice
when it's rotated anyway
the familiar one is more similar but
down here this one is more similar in
viewpoint yeah
and
these are not like those in
um well as little as possible as i say i
mean they've seen some but not very many
and they haven't seen these faces right
so you know when you when you're trying
to get those in innateness questions you
go as close to birth as you can but you
can't you know usually go into the very
moment of birth itself right and so
there's usually some experience and it's
a challenge but this is pretty early
yeah so couldn't that just mean that
like
the base perception network is just like
developed really quickly like right
after like it could it could based on
these data alone it could
um that's considered kind of unlikely
but i agree that that's consistent with
these data like you know in the first
two days of life the whole thing wires
itself up but that's be pretty unusual
it's not what you it's not really
consistent with those you know
samples of neurons that people have
looked at elsewhere in the brain but you
know maybe there's like a special little
circuit that just wires itself up really
fast so not likely but possible
okay all right
now you might say well
maybe there's some kind of simple visual
features that are short of you know an
actual face representation here this
doesn't show us that this is something
about faces per se even though it can
generalize across viewpoints so it's
it's not just like pixel intensity right
um so what is the classic way we ask
this question in face perception where
we ask where is this really something
about faces or is it something about the
low-level perceptual properties of the
face
yeah
turn it upside down god's gift to the
face researcher right
um
so
uh
oh i guess that was not on this slide
okay right okay so now in the next
experiment they present whole faces
or just the internal features without
hair or just the external features
without hair
so
the infants can do that at the top they
know those two are different they can do
this here and they can do that there
okay not too shocking yet just tells you
any of those cues can support
performance
but
now we can ask is that just pattern
matching
no it's not because when you turn them
upside down you find that
only
let's see it's only performance in this
case
that suffers when you turn them upside
down not this case or that case
okay so that shows that there are a
variety of cues here the infants can be
using but when you show them just the
internal features the actual
face proper
that part the ability to do this
discrimination goes away when you turn
it upside down
so that part at least seems to be at
least somewhat phase specific or has a
signature of face-specific processing
make sense
okay i mean as a pattern
it'd be just as easy to recognize this
upside down and distinguish it from that
upside down if it was just the pixels
you were registering but if you were
doing face processing that's something
like adult face processing you'd expect
that inversion effect
okay
all right so um
so where are we oh and i should just say
like
even this is actively debated in fact
the author of this study
um
considers this not to be evidence that
that uh that that processing is face
specific i think she's got some of the
strongest evidence ever but she's got
some counter-argument about how in the
inverted phases they don't look as long
in the habituation phase and so it's
like i'm telling you these cool methods
but boy every one of them can be fought
over
okay
so where are we um we've just shown the
discrimination of individual identity is
present very in very young newborns
recognition across viewpoints
and inversion effects are all present
within the first few days of life
okay so newborns have very impressive
face perception abilities
um and that's particularly surprising
given that their acuity is terrible
right their their vision is really
blurry uh for for young infants so it's
amazing that they can do these things
but now there's room for quibbling about
whether this is really a face-specific
system right so the inversion effect is
suggestive but they haven't totally
nailed the case about what's being
tapped into here is it really face
perception per se something specific to
face perception or is it some more
generic kind of
object perception okay and further we
want to know what happens after that
okay
so um you don't need to memorize this
table i'm just gonna make a few simple
points with it there are lots and lots
of studies where people have tested
behaviorally all kinds of different
aspects of face perception and the basic
story is that by age four
you see the little smiley face means
that you know this you know adult-like
property of the face perception system
is present by age four so all of those
signatures of face perception that are
present in adults are present by age
four
okay
and in fact much of the action is much
before that
um you can see that all of these things
are present at the earliest age they've
ever been tested the little square means
nobody's tested it at that age right so
um you know all this stuff is developing
very fast
right
okay
um
one particularly important thing here
that you read about a little bit but
that i want to take a moment to make
sure you understand because it's so
interesting and cool
is the phenomenon of perceptual
narrowing okay and this happens in face
perception and it happens in
phoneme perception in speech
and i'm going to do a demo here so i'm
going to show you a monkey face briefly
okay it's going to come on in a second
and you just look at it here we go boom
there it is okay
okay in a moment i'm going to show you
another monkey face
and you're gonna say shout out same if
you think it's the same and different if
you think it's different
and huh if you don't know
how many people don't know
yeah
it's different right
okay well okay maybe that was too hard
let's try it with a human okay remember
how hard that was now let's try it with
a human face i'm going to show you a
human face everybody ready here we go
okay
okay and i'm going to show you another
human and you're going to say is it same
or different
here we go
duh
easy right
okay
so here's the amazing thing
you were better at that monkey face task
when you were six months old
you could do that monkey face task when
you were six months old
one of the things that you have learned
from experience is that you don't need
that information and you threw away your
ability to do that but you had it when
you were six months old
isn't that awesome and interesting
okay that's called perceptual narrowing
okay so the experiments in particular do
the following you use that preferential
looking paradigm
the preferential looking to the novel
face in infants as your measure of
discrimination ability what can they
discriminate okay and so you show two
human faces two different individuals
like this
and so now uh what you see is that at
six months nine months in adulthood uh
people preferentially look to the
um novel face more than the familiar
face okay that's just what we've just
done people like to look at the new
thing not the old thing okay
um
however
if we do six months nine months oh yeah
that's what we just said okay they can
do that so now if you try this on monkey
faces
you find that adults
are like you know us we're barely able
to tell the familiar from the novel
we're not so good at monkey-faced
discrimination
nine-month-olds are the same
but
[Music]
at six months
infants can discriminate the monkey
faces
and you could too if somebody had asked
you
okay
so
um
there's very similar phenomena with
phonemes like those of you who are not
native speakers of english may be aware
of some phonemes in english if you
learned it relatively late that are hard
for you to discriminate
um there are sounds in uh hindi i forget
it's like a da and a ta that sound
identical to me but that are just like
completely obviously different to native
hindi speakers
and all languages have this so of the
kinds of phonemes that are discriminated
in any language in the world you could
discriminate all of those when you were
six months old
and one of the things you do when you
learn a language is just throw together
in the same bag things that are actually
different that other people can
discriminate if your language doesn't
discriminate
okay
and so you get that with phonemes and
you get it with faces
okay everybody get what perceptual
narrowing is okay
okay you also get this i mentioned this
way back uh with perceiving faces of
other races right not just faces of
other species but if you grow up in an
environment where you're
uh only
exposed to
races a b and c and you later have to
discriminate faces of races d e and f
you're not so good at it
right all the same deal okay
um
all right
so
how would we know
whether this change
between six months and older
is just maturation it's just some kind
of developmental program that's going on
on autopilot independent of what you see
or whether it's learned from experience
josh
you control for experience absolutely
like the sugita paper
okay so we'll get to that in a second so
we started with these key questions what
is the initial state at birth and we
showed impressive perceptual abilities
within a few days
although people dispute whether those
abilities are a face-specific system
and we don't know much about what that
system is other than it works
surprisingly well given the low acuity
and we showed that how it changes after
that there's perceptual narrowing
between 6 and 12 months
but a great deal is not known about what
happens then and so now we're on to this
question of how are we going to
unconfound
the what changes after birth whether
it's maturation or experience
and i'm not going to have time to get to
these other awesome methods we're going
to focus on controlled rearing of which
you read the sugita paper okay
so just to remind you of the basics most
of you seem to get the paper just fine
the big idea was again using this
preferential looking method what sugita
at all showed
is that when they reared monkeys for six
12 or 24 months without ever letting
them see a face and then tested them on
the very first session that they ever
saw faces
they found with prep preferential
looking
they found that on the very first
exposure to faces the monkeys looked
more at faces compared to novel objects
right they showed that face preference
sort of akin to the
infants looking at the paddle
and they discriminated between faces
very similar faces with adult-like
accuracy
in this part i don't know if you found
it surprising but when this paper came
out i was like whoa
that is crazy right because as i said
the whole space of sensible hypotheses
is okay maybe a lot of stuff is innate
but you're still going to need
experience to tone it up for god's sake
right who would think the entire adult
ability
could exist without any experience at
all so i don't know if you had that
reaction but i think that's a sensible
reaction it's a pretty astonishing
finding in that paper
unfortunately there's one author on that
paper it was done once and it's such a
labor-intensive study that probably
nobody will ever try to replicate it so
in the back of many people's minds is
like really can that really be true or
it's like is there something funny here
so i hope somebody replicates it someday
but
um
but it hasn't been done yet
okay the other thing that you guys
presumably noticed is there was
perceptual narrowing in that study there
were many interesting things in there
it's actually quite a rich paper
but after the initial testing session no
matter how long the deprivation the
monkeys were then housed in either an
environment with just humans or just
monkeys
and so whether that was 6 12 or 24
months after birth alder all of face
deprivation they then
lost their ability at that point to
discriminate the unexperienced faces
okay so they went through perceptual
narrowing did that all make sense to you
guys you got that good
okay
all right so anyway that suggests that
an awful lot of the face perception
system uh is present without any
exposure to faces and that's pretty
astonishing
okay what experience seems to do there
is not create abilities but eliminate
them right for the
species that you don't see
okay
so first reaction really
uh second reaction is there any way to
account for this in terms of some
non-phase specific system i think you
can but it takes some work and the uh
counter explanations are really
difficult you could say well maybe this
was all being carried by some more
generic object system um they didn't
test inverted faces unfortunately
if but it was carried by a generic
object system why would you find the
perceptual narrowing why would they have
lost their ability for the unexperienced
species so i think that story is hard to
tell
and of course other question i'm sure
you guys are wondering is what is going
on in those monkeys brains yeah
okay so let's get to that let's talk
about what we know about development of
this system by looking at brains um and
first of all there's been lots of work
on this in older kids age five and up
going back uh over a decade
it's now clear that all of that basic
machinery i showed you is present by age
five in most kids age five it's
continuing to change after that but you
can detect most of that stuff by age
five or six or seven something like that
okay
trouble is that's cool but age five is
late right with respect to experience
and with respect to all those behavioral
abilities that i showed you
so uh we need to go earlier
and so a couple years ago rebecca sacks
who's
straight up there two floors up
um
started scanning infants okay and this
is as heather can tell you almost
impossible
it is right on the edge okay
it took rebecca and her lab many many
years of work over five years just to
get the system going
there were all kinds of technical
advances like making scanning coils that
were optimized for infants and
comfortable for infants
rebecca herself went to great lengths
including
producing some of her own subjects
that's her son arthur there and her two
um grad that her grad student in postdoc
who were working with her
um but all of this massive effort was
worth it because what they found was
first for comparison this is adults with
a contrast of faces versus scenes okay
so this is basically the ppa in blue
responding more to scenes
and the ffa in here and some other face
selective bits responding more to faces
and adults
what do you see in six month old infants
it's astonishingly similar
right you can really see a very similar
layout
of the functional organization of the
brain already by six months
okay
so that's a huge advance that pushes way
back the timeline
by which these things had developed
previously everybody's talking about oh
what changes after age five age five
come on okay it's mostly there by age
six okay
now importantly
um though it's these systems are not
adult-like their selectivities are very
different those regions are less
selective in infants than they are in
adults but the spatial layout
is there already by six months
um
and that importantly constrains whatever
our model is of development that pushes
it way back
okay so now the next questions are
what is it about that region or those
particular regions that makes them
become face specific right
uh already by six months how do how does
it how does the face system know to take
up residence in that systematic location
in the brain
and what is the role of experience in
their construction
and how could we ever answer this
and one way to answer that is to use an
animal model okay
so there's been yes
can you ask a similar question about
i sorry i didn't hear about what um
general physical layout like why why
does your stomach always come in the
same place um and would it
maybe be the same mechanism that uh
guides like
development of any organs and the layout
of the body
yes
now i don't know much about how hearts
and kidneys and livers develop but my
understanding is that's pretty much kind
of wired in like there's some
there's some
chunks of dna that tell you how to build
a kidney and where to put in your body
right
and so that is one of the hypotheses
here it's a tempting hypothesis right
there's all that structure it's a very
tempting hypothesis
but that doesn't mean it's necessarily
right
yeah it's absolutely it's it's a
hypothesis we should consider and take
seriously
yeah
okay
so but we want data we want to find out
okay so animal models
so starting a few years ago marge
livingstone over at harvard med school
over there a couple miles over there
started doing these also really
amazingly heroic studies where she was
scanning infant monkeys okay now this is
really hard to read so let me tell you
what we got here
we have the cortex this is all the same
animal at different time points in each
of these things is the cortex unfolded
mathematically and flattened so you can
see the whole thing i don't expect you
to know what's where i can barely tell
myself
uh but if you look at it what you see is
at 81 days of age there's just blue
stuff there's no orange stuff the orange
stuff is the face selective response in
fact if you look down you start to see
oh that looks yeah yeah okay that looks
pretty systematic starts replicating
after that
okay and so the claim is you don't see
face selectivity until about 170 days
after birth in monkeys okay that's about
here here's another monkey for
comparison if you stare at it you'll see
okay there's these systematic bits boom
boom boom boom
and maybe a little hint at 170 but you
know there's some garbage up there but
nothing systematic before that
yeah
so there's no control over here of the
environment this is like monkeys normal
monkeys who have exposure to human faces
and monkey faces hanging out in the lab
yeah we haven't gone to controlled
hearing yet it's coming okay first thing
is just when does it develop in monkeys
okay
all right so
are you surprised by this
it's not there here it is there there
you should be surprised why are you
surprised
is this what you guys predicted quietly
i guess you surprised me uh
yeah
what is up with that
absolutely
the sugita paper really made it look
like that system was innate right no
experience boom they're fine it was just
behavior but it was a good behavioral
study so why the hell isn't it here
everybody with the program how
surprising that is
um okay so a bunch of things
first of all and it gets stable after
that right and and replicable well the
first thing is one's a behavioral
measure and one's a neural measure
maybe those fabulous behavioral measures
weren't actually being driven by some
phase specific system wouldn't that be
sad right i mean they did lots of
controls it was a nice idea i thought
they did as well as they could but who
knows maybe
those monkeys could do that task with
some other system and they didn't need
their face system for it that's one
possibility right then you could have
the face system not develop till later
but the monkeys could do it before
but the other thing is
noticed that sugita didn't test their
monkeys until
that the youngest ones six months of age
so maybe
um it just got wired up just before
right there right they were tested okay
so it seemed contradictory at first but
it's not completely literally
contradictory
yeah
okay
um
all right so now
the fact that this stuff doesn't show up
until here
does that mean that this face system
requires experience to develop
you know the answer because whenever i
ask that question the answer is always
no why does it why does that not imply
that you need experience with faces to
wire up it's tempting you look at it's
like okay you had to look at faces all
this time before you wired it up but
there it is very tempting
but is it jessica no
so what's your name
bailey oh sorry you told me that like
six times
merely
due to
i'm sure physical yeah could be just
maturation i keep making the same point
because it's important
right just because it shows up later
doesn't mean it's learned
right maybe it's like puberty or height
or something like that it's on some
developmental program that's just going
to unfold independent of what you see
okay
so
how would we find out
we would do controlled rearing and
that's exactly what these guys did
okay
so in another paper that just came out a
couple years ago
they raised baby monkeys without ever
letting them see a face much like sugita
did they use welder's masks every time
they were in the lab so the monkeys
never got to see faces
and like sugita they went to lengths to
treat the monkeys nicely they heard the
calls of their con specifics they got
lots of attention they had rich visual
experience they just didn't see faces so
it sounds kind of tragic and horrible at
first but it's actually not that bad
they had social contact and visual
experience they just never saw faces
okay
both this study and the sugita study all
right
okay so they can hear and smell other
monkeys
um
so the face deprived monkeys saw no
faces at all until 90 days old and at
that point they went straight into the
scanner okay and the first time they saw
faces was inside an mri machine getting
scanned okay
so what do you think are the face
deprived monkeys gonna show face patches
so there's no way to tell because we
have all these contradictory bits of
evidence here
right
from sugita you might think yes
hard to tell so let's just look at the
data okay so here first is a normally
um normally reared monkey 260 days old
just for comparison and those are those
face patches in yellow
in
two different monkeys here b4 and b5
left and right hemisphere okay so those
yellow bits are the face patches okay
normal 260 day old monkey now we're
going to see a face deprived monkey 260
days old this monkey was face deprived
that entire time
up until scanning
no face patches
the plot thickens
no face patches at all
so these guys published this paper in a
very high profile journal and said that
this is the title of the paper seeing
faces is necessary for face domain
formation
okay face domain just means face
selective patch
okay
everybody see
you deprive them of face experience you
don't see it
okay that's pretty interesting
um and it strongly suggests that the
face system is not an a but depends on
face experience
doesn't it
rare casework the answer is yes it does
okay
uh and it feels like it contradicts the
sugita finding right
but not exactly you could still wiggle
out of it right you could say okay
the thing that sugita was studying
doesn't use those patches so it's not
flat out contradictory sugita was
measuring behavior these guys are
looking at brains it's kind of
unsatisfying but it's in principle
possible
me and everyone else has been nudging
these guys to run the sugita behavioral
experiment on your monkeys please
and i gather that's getting going but i
haven't seen any of the data yet
yeah so we don't know how that's going
to result okay so let's take stock what
is what is the initial state we show
with behavior that there is both
attention to faces and um
in present in newborn humans and face
specificity seems like it but it's not
totally nailed
uh whereas functional mri says there's
no evidence for face specificity at
birth at least in monkeys right that's
other
yeah okay so how are we going to
reconcile this with all the behavioral
results i showed you that there seems to
be a lot of face abilities present in
newborns
well one possibility is that face
specificity exists that behaviorally
but mri feels oh sorry phase specificity
exists in the brain but mri fails to
detect it
right there's a whole rhythm rule about
whether functional mri works well in
infants it's barely possible as i
mentioned it's also hard with infant
monkeys their blood flow regulation is
different they're squirming and wiggling
there are a million issues with scanning
babies whether human or monkey and so
you could always say well it was there
and just the mri data are just kind of
crappy or blood flow regulation to the
brain develops later an argument many
people have made
however a paper was published last week
that argues against that hypothesis
the same group just showed that the
sonata sensory touch system
is totally in place by 11 days in baby
monkeys
so that suggests that you can get really
nice functional mri data at 11 days of
age in baby monkeys and it makes it less
likely that this is some kind of
spurious failure to detect something
that was actually there
okay
i'm not going to test you on every
little detail here i want you to think
about the logic of how you can ask these
questions okay
um okay the other possibility is that
the face abilities that we showed
behaviorally are using some more generic
object recognition system not using this
face selective system in the brain
okay
so how does it change over time well we
showed that behaviorally in humans at
least all the hallmarks of
phase-specific processing are present by
h4 and we get this perceptual narrowing
between 6 and 12 months
but then we show that with functional
mri at least in monkeys there's no
evidence for face specificity before 200
days
i gather they're working on it
but i haven't seen any of the data yet
yeah um
okay so
though that lack of face specificity is
consistent with the idea that all that
human early face recognition behavior is
driven by a different system because
they don't have their face system yet
presumably
but it's also consistent with this idea
that you know it's just failing to be
detected
even though i said that's probably not
true given you can detect other stuff it
might be true here
the ability to see things with mri
depend depends where you're looking at
the brain
so
okay
so what about
these causal roles of structured
experience
um
and uh biological maturation okay so we
argued that early face experience isn't
crucial for the face recognition system
that was the sugita paper you read
but now functional mri is showing that
face experience
is necessary for the development of face
patches
at least in monkeys
and so a very sensible reaction is what
what what how are we going to make sense
of this this is a big conundrum
it's going to get worse on monday where
there's yet more contradictory data
and further if that face system
isn't innate
then what if anything is innate about
face perception
right so
maybe what all these data are telling us
is not that much
maybe just a bias to look at faces
or some very simple image template
that's sufficient in the environment of
infants to get them to look at faces
right so there's a lot of studies i
didn't have time to work into this
lecture where people stick cameras on
the foreheads of
newborns and they collect what is the
typical visual experience of a newborn
and then you can take that you can take
that experience and ask what kind of
you know you can write
machine learning code to say what would
you have to build in to reliably pick
out the faces in typical infant input
it's probably not that complicated
because infants don't see that many
different kinds of things right
okay
we showed early visual discrimination
abilities
faces in newborn infants but again it's
not clear that's part of the specific
system
and we showed that the face patches at
least in monkeys seem to require
experience okay i'm just recapping here
but now there's this big question of
how do those face patches know where to
develop in the brain right like here
they are in humans these little purple
blobs the occipital face area i've got
two different fusiform face areas
because
various people think there's two i'm not
sure i don't really care doesn't matter
anyway how do they know to land right
there
okay we keep bringing up this question
and dancing around it but so far i've
given you no
no
basis for thinking about this
one possibility
is that
infants monkey and humans
are born with some earlier kind of
selectivity of that patch of brain
it's not a whole like face template it's
not a whole face system maybe it's a
bias for curvy things
right and then somehow that makes the
faces land there and the system wires
itself up it's not exactly clear how
that would go
but that's one kind of story
story is based on this fact i told you
at the beginning of the lecture which is
most of the long-range connectivity of
the brain is present at birth
and so maybe the particular connections
of that patch of brain
are already there at birth and maybe
that patch of connections are sufficient
to somehow gate the input to that system
and arrange for it to end up being phase
specific
okay
so this is a very active area of
investigation
and there's other very active ongoing
kinds of investigation where people are
trying to understand how this
development might work
one way people are looking at this i
mentioned this briefly but i think it's
super exciting as people are asking with
deep nets and other kinds of modeling
what do you have to build into a system
to get it to produce face recognition
abilities
if you're if you're trying to make a
deep net you're trying to make it really
good at face recognition
do you need to give it a template of
faces do you need to give it only
experience with faces what do you need
to build into it to get it to be really
good right and so that's a very active
area of investigation
and you can actually some ongoing work
with
jim de carlo's lab we're asking okay
deep nets don't have topography next
door units in a deep net doesn't mean
anything what's next door versus far
apart location doesn't need anything in
a deep net but you can make it mean
something and then you can ask
when and whether and how and why you get
face patches
in a deep net
okay and what computational role they
serve well totally weirdly i'm i'm
finishing early but i'm not going to
finish i'll take questions and then i'll
maybe add a little bit more
um i think that was all i had here right
um any questions about all this
if it feels a little bit chaotic so i've
sort of said x and not x and x but
they're not exactly x and not x they're
just yeah sure do um so fmri can detect
activity and like fossils right and with
fossils you said we can contain millions
of neurons
so um is it possible that
the neurons that are specific to places
are distributed at an ova throughout the
brain and somehow the function kind of
think it's spatially clustered yeah but
the neurons themselves already exist
absolutely that's a great hypothesis
it's absolutely possible everybody get
the idea you have all those face neurons
at birth and maybe they're face specific
at birth but they're spatially spread
out and then they have to find each
other
and hang out together next to each other
before you ever get an mri signal it's
totally possible logically it seems to
me quite unlikely actually because it
can be very hard for all those neurons
with their necessary connections which
is after all how they become face
specific is what their inputs are and
what they're connected to it'd be very
hard for them to migrate spatially
across the brain
maintaining their connections yes you're
going to push back go forward like mine
grades they should be liquid functional
but since you said like
review they care about what their papers
are doing so maybe it's just like on
every mirror on hobbies but the you know
next week that's and this chain moves it
back until like that orientation but
that deprivation is the most efficient
way to have all that it's totally
possible totally possible
absolutely
yep
other questions this is kind of wide
open nobody knows
right
let me just see what else i have time
for briefly
um
so funny i took out all these slides
because i just thought i'm going to
run out of time and go over and drive
everyone crazy
and i moved all this stuff to the other
lecture
maybe i will just
hmm
all right hang on let me just glance at
the lineup for
wednesday
yeah is there
the perceptual narrowing
is really
surprising fascinating
does anybody have a
model for
how that processing might work or what
it might be for i mean it feels like a
lot of the um assumptions or like the
sort of the common sense assumptions
um when we look at fmri and
you know when we look at
neural signals is that they all mean
positive things
um but maybe a lot of the signals a lot
of activity might be inhibitory
you know might be the opposite
totally yeah but how would that explain
perceptual narrowing
well if if what you're learning is what
to ignore then maybe it takes a lot of
effort to ignore things and um
and uh
you know i'm not really i'm not you
exactly yeah no it's a good point that
like you know i mentioned at the
beginning one of the
limitations of functional mri is we
don't know what the actual
neurophysiological basis of the bold
signal is it could be anything that that
increases your metabolic costs and hence
changes blood flow but one of the things
that increases metabolic costs is
inhibiting other neurons right and so
way back in the early days of actually
pet imaging before functional mri came
along there was kind of an early proto
version of a face specific paper it
wasn't didn't nail everything but it was
it was not bad for 1981 when i think it
was published
and the person who did that paper
justine sergio
argued that it's very very ambiguous
what it means to find a hot spot in the
brain where the activity the metabolic
activity is higher say when you look at
faces that are than objects their point
was that could be the part of the brain
that really sucks at face recognition
that's the part that's going ah i can't
deal with this thing what is this thing
right that's really bad at it and the
neurons are firing a lot it's sort of
facetious but sort of not right and
that's probably not the right account
but it is an important reminder that we
actually don't know
um what actual kind of neural activity
is driving those things and whether it's
um
whether it's excitatory or inhibitory
absolutely uh hang on one second i feel
like there was another part of what you
said that i was going to engage on no it
would feel it feels like somehow
possibly connected to the the potential
yeah
yeah possibly we'd have to work it out
um in one of the lectures
i mentioned about other racing factors
yeah and then probably
based on the experiment
or the child for some adult kid
yes
okay long range wiring
okay which is very different than all
the circuits that live in each little
patch of cortex remember i showed you
this big change in the complexity of
neurons and their
uh the number of connections
oops except we've lost it
now um
right so they're changing a lot within
each patch of cortex right so those
local circuits that are doing
computations are surely changing a lot
over the first couple years it's just a
long range connections between that
patch and some remote region like where
it gets its inputs and where it sends
its outputs to
um but hang on a second you asked
something um
there's also very interesting stuff
about the other race effect i did
mention that a a month ago or so didn't
i which is another version of this
uh perceptual narrowing
and in fact a friend of mine who's a
great face researcher has not yet
published this paper but she found the
following totally that's right you
mentioned the adoption studies right so
what she has done is ask
did i tell you guys about this already i
feel like i did but maybe not anyway so
if you what you find is that people are
you know you know they all look alike
whoever they are if you've seen fewer of
them than whoever we are
you are less good at discriminating them
that's just what it is
but so eleanor mccone asked if there's a
um
if there's a developmental timeline for
getting your way out of the other race
effect
and so what she did was she's in
australia and she got various
communities of people who moved from you
know dominant racial composition x to
dominant racial composition y
and who made that move at different ages
and so what she finds is that actually
much like learning the phonemes of a
language which you know even if you use
okay let me back up a second i said that
with phonemes you can discriminate all
those phonemes of all the world's
languages at birth and by six months
you've thrown away the abilities for all
the phonemes you can't discriminate
however
if you then go learn a foreign language
sometime between six months and say 12
you can become a native speaker so you
can learn them back right so there's
another window gets narrowed but you
still have a window to learn the back
okay
after you're like 12 15 whatever forget
it you won't be a native speaker right
same deal with the other race effect
this is exactly what mccoy found with
the other race effect
people who moved to a different dominant
racial
community
um learned the ability to kind of
natively discriminate people in that
other race if they moved before age 12.
so it really seems like there's some
general ability oh i remember david's
other question why does this make sense
i don't know exactly why it makes sense
but certainly
neural activity is expensive
metabolically
and we don't want to make discrimination
we don't have to
and so it can it can be just that the
nervous system is learning what kinds of
discriminations it needs to make in its
environment and what kind it doesn't
right and with the case of phonemes it's
actually part of what you're doing in
speech perception is you want to know
like every time
you know i say ba it sounds different in
all different contexts and so part of
the
essence of the difficulty in speech
recognition is understanding that all
those different bars are the same sound
right
and so part of what perceptual narrowing
might be doing is kind of saying all
those things you know da ta whatever it
is in hindi um those are all going to
count as the same thing
and that's going to help you process
speech in your native language but
hinder you when you try to learn a
foreign language
yeah so something i'm wondering with um
perceptual narration is like how
general like the starting point is so
i'm basically wanted because in the
studies they've like compared human and
monkey faces yeah and i'm wondering if
there's any correlation with how similar
the dna is if the thought like how
they're able to discriminate between the
faces so whether that's like different
types of monkeys or like different
animals i'm not getting it right early
on they can discriminate you can
discriminate both right
so what's the question so i'm wondering
like what other animals can they
discriminate and what i see i see how
far does it go yeah good question
i don't know that anybody has asked
little kids if they can discriminate
other kinds of
faces other than monkey faces
um i'm sure there's some limit to it
like fish faces
probably i don't know
yeah
um
but there's also actually in terms of
that extended i don't know the answer to
that yeah there's going to be some limit
but in terms of the question of um how
far you can accept you know
how long can you relearn those abilities
or maintain them it's not like
perceptual narrowing um is going to
happen at six months automatically so if
you manipulate it so the the studies on
humans
if you send i feel like i said this in
here before but it must have been
somewhere else
if you send parents home
with books with monkey pictures in them
parents of six month olds
and you say look every night go through
the book with your kids and say there's
monkey joe and there's monkey bob and
there's monkey whoever with your kids
and you have them do that from age six
months to 12 months they don't
perceptually narrow because they
continue to get that experience
right
interestingly
if the parents go home and just say look
look
that doesn't do it
you have to give them some social cue
that is essentially saying this thing is
different from that thing
if you do that with an infant even they
don't really understand language much
they get that cue and they learn to
discriminate or they maintain their
ability to discriminate monkey faces
yeah does that hold up even when they're
like past 12 months old
uh well i'm guessing it will be just
like the case that uh mccone showed with
other race effects right i'm guessing
the other species effect would be
like the other race effect in that if
you say start working in a monkey lab
when you're eight years old
that would be weird but you could
or you
i don't know whatever anyway that you
would be able to relearn it
on the same time scale that you would
relearn
um you know relearn or learn for the
first time uh previously unfamiliar
races of faces but maybe those are
slightly different timelines
yeah
could you do something similar um with
like the monkey faces but would like
phonemes of different languages
i'm sure you can and i'm sure that has
been done but i don't know that
literature yeah yeah you mean like keep
well okay i mean it essentially does get
done right so kids who stay in
environments
let me think about this well certainly a
a an infant who's being raised in a
bilingual environment will maintain
their ability to discriminate those
phonemes from any of the languages they
hear right
it's you're saying that like with the
monkeys i need like some kind of social
cue
to like know that i suspect that's true
i don't know this literature well enough
i do know yeah actually it's coming back
dimly heather do you know this janet
werker
i okay so janet werker is this amazing
infant phoneme perception researcher and
i'm pretty sure
that if you present infants with just
like a tv in the background with a
foreign language
um even if the infant doesn't have much
else to do that's not enough and you
need to like look at them and engage
with them and speak mother ease like hey
infant blah blah right
i think you need to do all of that for
them to maintain it but i'm yeah that's
correct i think it also has to be
interaction they can't also
be watching there's been confidence
it has to be what it has to be like a
lot it can't be yeah like skype
personally yeah which might somebody was
like joint and gen or something like you
can interact in different ways in person
oh
yeah
question about like how long that can
last like if someone's
someone spoke for a language when they
were younger and moved somewhere else if
we're adopted then they stop speaking
behind us
would they
um sort of contain that ability
i don't know i'm sure there's a
literature on that you don't know that
dana do you sorry like so you're you're
raised bilingual and then you stop
having the experience early on from your
second language and then you're
re-exposed later
at age eight
yeah you still have the
but then that's not consistent with
perceptual narrowing
if you're exposed before two years yeah
yeah and then you move away
if it goes beyond that six month thing
yeah okay
i think that's the case yeah you might
not have the higher structure but if you
like you learn
the syntax and some vocabulary like
you'll have a better accent than someone
who did not have that early experience
might not be able to differentiate
emotions
but we just talked about this
okay good one more question josh so do
we know cases where there's like
an inclusive sort of mismatch between
fmri and bayern munich sort of
information
like like this yeah like but this
probably in some other domain of some of
those
you know basically images
oh god i don't have my you know
dictionary of knowledge filed that way
so i can pull up an instance of that but
i'm sure there are loads of those
yeah well because when we because we're
making all these assumptions about which
behavioral ability is subserved by some
particular activation in the brain and
mostly we don't know
right we know we know when we have the
rare opportunities to do causal tests we
have a better idea that that system is
at least causally involved in that
behavioral ability
um but yeah often those links are much
looser than we'd like
all right see you guys wednesday
you